[Musik]
na wer kommt mit denn da entgegen wer
kommt mir denn da entgegen freundliche
Begrüßung im Treppenhaus na was machen
meine kleinen flohtransporter komm bist
aber ein bisschen dick geworden ne der
Schornsteinfeger kommt Termin bei
Barbara Palm in Berlin-Kreuzberg sie
lebt mit Mops und Katze auf 60
Quadratmetern
rapsilber kontrolliert vorm Winter ob
die Brennkammer in Ordnung ist hier in
Kreuzberg gibt es noch jede Menge
solcher Öfen aber kaum Brennstoff
gut okay aber ansonsten bin ich erstmal
soweit zufrieden und hoffe du kommst
dann auch durch und hast du genug Kohle
Kohlen her kriege Bauhaus
hi nimmt für die Lieferung bis hier oben
120 Euro früher sagt sie hat sie in der
Woche für sechs Euro Briketts verfeuert
heute kostet die gleiche Menge 5 mal
mehr auf Fleisch verzichtet sie aber
frieren will sie nicht
ich finde ich bin so alt geworden ich
muss jetzt hier nicht noch im Kalten
sitzen ja egal was die Regierung sagt ja
und ich finde sowieso dass das alles
diese ganze Verteuerung ist künstlich
herbeigeholt denke ich ja wenn wie kann
man jetzt Kernkraftwerke abstellen
kannst du das mal erklären ich weiß es
nicht ich bin auch nicht für Atomkraft
aber es ist der falsche Moment ne
trotz hoher Energiepreise macht sie sich
keine Sorgen um die Zukunft zumindest
nicht um ihre eigene
das habe ich vielleicht maximal nur 20
Jahre ja gute Cook ist mir den ganzen
Scheiß hier an und dann geht ins Nirvana
aber was ist wenn ich eine Familie habe
mit kleinen Kindern oder oder du hast
jetzt Enkel oder was weiß ich du hast
doch einen Kopf voll du weißt doch gar
nicht was aus den wird mit diesen ganzen
dreckener Umwelt wir haben so eine
schöne Welt verstehst du und die wird in
die Tonne getreten also die Welt
verbessern kann der Schornsteinfeger
nicht aber einen energiespartipp hat er
für Frau Rapp weil merkt man das ein
bisschen was durch pfeift wenn man hier
oben anfasst dämmendes Klebeband für ein
paar Euro könnte hier bares Geld sparen
alle rapsilber nennt sich selbst den
kiezkehrer sein Kiez Berlin Kreuzberg
wir leben rund 300.000 Menschen viele
Gebäude aus der Gründerzeit rund um das
Zentrum Cottbusser Tor
[Musik]
rapsilber ist seit 30 Jahren
Schornsteinfeger seit zehn Jahren
unterwegs in Kreuzberg Kamine fegen
Feuerstätten begutachten erkennt viele
Wohnungen sieht wie es den Menschen geht
und wie ihre Armut wächst ob die Leute
jetzt hungern das weiß ich nicht aber
ich glaube die Leute überlegen schon was
sie wann wo Einkaufen zu welchem Preisen
und was sie dann auch davon essen
vielleicht wird auch weniger
weggeschmissen
der nächste Termin das Hotel am
Hermannplatz die Gasheizung hat
aussetzer muss komplett ersetzt werden
rapsilber prüft die
Anschlussmöglichkeiten für eine neue
effektive Heizung
Ragnar Kilian der Hotelbesitzer hofft
auf eine günstige Lösung er hatte in der
Pandemie schon viel Geld verloren es
geht es gleiche wieder los und hat man
sich ein bisschen erholt und jetzt ja es
kommt die Energie Sache die natürlich
genauso ein fertig macht naja den alten
Ofen in Zimmer 16 will der Hotelier
wieder in Betrieb nehmen Kosten sparen
wo es geht seine Stromrechnung doppelt
so hoch wie früher fürs Gas zahlt er
jetzt schon dreimal so viel das ist
meine Existenz halt ne und wenn nicht
irgendwo was passiert dann habe ich
Angst natürlich dass ich zu machen muss
du weißt ja auch nicht wie geht's weiter
kommt wieder Corona wo sie alle Angst
haben passiert wieder was also natürlich
habe
auf jeden Fall habe ich Angst ob ich es
halten kann und ob ich bin schon viermal
umgekippt ob ich hetzen das vielleicht
durch Stress und Arbeit wieder umkippe
möchte ich nicht normal leben immerhin
der Ofen ist so weit in Ordnung gute
Nachrichten für den Hotelbetreiber vom
Zustand Heli Kacheln sind soweit okay
oben die Decke ist okay
wirklich nur einmal sauber machen lassen
und dann hier vorne wieder gangbar
machen damit das halt auch benutzt
werden kann in den Ofenbauer soll die
Brennkammer reinigen dann kann der Ofen
wieder heizen super ganz lieb es Zeit
genommen hast das in diesem Winter mehr
Kaminöfen gebraucht werden da ist sich
rapsilber sicher jeder Ofen der wirklich
gut benutzt wird und bewusst benutzt
wird bringt halt Entlastung fürs Gas und
Stromnetz für die Zukunft und nächstes
Jahr werden wir erst die gasprobleme
kriegen dann war die die Gase nicht so
schnell kriegen kleine Betriebe und
Hotels wie dieses machen für rapsilber
den Kiez aus sie müssen unbedingt
erhalten bleiben und bräuchten mehr
Unterstützung
ich weiß dass er fleißig ist und durch
seine eigene Hände Arbeit irgendwie das
nicht mehr richtig hinkriegen wird und
dass das was mich ärgert das durch ja
Entscheidungen Dritter die in bestimmten
Bereichen nicht überall schlau
durchdacht sind andere so zu Schaden
kommen und das ist ja kein Einzelfall
das ist was du nicht persönlich immer
ärgert das Leute trotz Arbeit irgendwie
ist nicht richtig schaffen dann auf die
Beine zu kommen oder auf den beiden zu
bleiben trotz allem Fragner Kilian
bleibt zuversichtlich gerade laufen die
Buchungen fürs nächste Jahr an
2023 das macht doch Hoffnung
ja der Ordner ist 2023 fertig ist das
schon wir haben auch ein paar Gäste
schon und ja aber viele stornieren auch
schon viele buchen einfach so und dann
komplett sich kurz danach wieder die
Stornierung also ist dann mal ein
bisschen schade aber ich hoffe
Schornsteinfeger sind auch
Energieberater immer und überall auch im
Hinterhof die Heizkörper sauber machen
Thermostate freistellen und bei
frühlingshaften Temperaturen auch mal
die Fenster offen lassen wieder mal
draußen wärmer als
aufmachen damit genau
die Fenster auf ist auch sinnvoll genau
Thomas Schütte ist Rentner hat bis vor
kurzem als Pfleger gearbeitet
energiesparen ist für ihn existenziell
erachtet penibel auf seinen
Energieverbrauch achtet darauf dass der
Kessel auch immer ein bisschen laut
zentriert steht seine Wohnung wird er im
Winter auf maximal 18 Grad heizen sich
zu und warm anziehen sparen wo er nur
kann es gibt auch keine großen Reserven
und das ist dann schon beängstigend weil
das geht dann an die Existenz dafür
haben sie dann Angst dass ich hier meine
Wohnung aufgeben muss und nicht weiß
wohin
scheint irgendwie
zwar also man hat ein bisschen Problem
damit sich das wirklich vorzustellen
aber man weiß das ist passieren kann
im Hinterhaus sind dann halt auch
wirklich die Leute die gucken müssen wie
sie über die Runden kommen und Wiese den
Monatsende oder des Monatsende irgendwie
überleben ohne Geld
schornsteinfegen hält fit Fahrstühle
sind hier selten aber in fast jeder
Altbauwohnung steht ein Ofen viele davon
haben Bestandsschutz wurden aber lange
nicht benutzt
die werden jetzt alle wieder abgestaubt
und ja gangbar gemacht wenn es dann
wirklich zum kalten Winter kommt seit
Kriegsbeginn in der Ukraine steht sein
Telefon kaum still mehr als 300 Anfragen
von Kunden die Ihren Ofen wieder nutzen
wollen wenn der Hauseigentümer
einverstanden ist kann der kiezkehrer
den Schornstein inspizieren und im
besten Fall sein Okay geben so wie hier
wer keinen alten Ofen hat und es sich
leisten kann kauft neu Hauptsache
unabhängig vom Gas Ofenbauer Erik Passow
arbeitet 60 Stunden die Woche viele
Anfragen lange Wartezeiten kaum Öfen
lieferbar
halbes Jahr bis zu über einem Jahr also
wir haben Geräte die sind
lieferfähig fünfte KW 24 natürlich freut
er sich über jeden verkauften Ofen weiß
aber auch die gestiegene Nachfrage nach
Holz lässt die Preise explodieren sind
noch immer genügend Leute die auch reine
Ofenheizung haben und die sind natürlich
auf dem Brennstoff angewiesen
und die sind jetzt so die Leidtragenden
die jetzt hier keine Brennstoffe mehr
bekommen Zwischenstopp im Café wieso oft
Telefon am Ohr die Chefin hat matekin
Clark über hohe Energiekosten sie
fürchtet dass sie bald 1800 Euro im
Monat zahlen muss bisher zahlt sie die
Hälfte
und nicht nur ich rede auch mit meinen
Kunden wir haben auch relativ Angst das
ist ja nicht normal steigende Kosten
auch an der Kuchentheke Thema
ich heiße noch gar nicht und ich glaube
ich werde auch ganz lange noch nicht
halt so wir Wärmflasche an den Füßen und
noch eine Decke drüber beim Arbeiten
harte Zeiten für alle
und es wäre sehr traurig wenn ich
deswegen nur meinen Namen aufgeben
müsste das sind die Sorgen die der
kiezkehrer inzwischen fast täglich hört
von seinen Kunden
mich macht es manchmal betroffen dass
man sieht dass die Leute jeden Tag früh
arbeiten gehen und trotzdem irgendwie am
Ende des Monats nichts haben wo sie
sagen oder können wir uns mal was
leisten oder so
sein eigener Job ist zur Zeit gefragt
wie nie noch viele im Kiez brauchen
seine Tipps und sein Wissen aber für
heute ist Schluss